Mortal Engines aimed to be a franchise-starting
epic, but it looks like the grandest thing
about it is the scale of its failure.
Here's how this hundred-million dollar book
adaptation turned into one of the biggest
box office bombs of 2018.
Mortal Engines is based on the 2001 book of
the same name by Philip Reeve, which launched
a seven-book series of sequels and prequels.
The post-apocalyptic story is based around
the premise of cities that are constantly
in motion, roaming the world in competition
with each other over resources.
The protagonist is a woman named Hester, who
wears a mask to hide scars she received from
a man named Thaddeus, an evil historian in
London who killed her mother.
To help get her vengeance on Thaddeus, Hester
joins up with a team of rebels who are fighting
to make cities stop preying on each other,
and go back to sitting still.
And that's honestly only the half of it.
As you might imagine, there's a lot going
on here.
"Just give it to me one more time, simpler."
Over the course of its debut weekend, Mortal
Engines made only $7.5 million at the domestic
box office, a crushingly low number that saw
the movie opening in fifth place.
The film fared better in foreign markets,
where it brought in nearly $35 million, with
the combined total making for an opening weekend
take of just over $42 million.
Relative to the movie's budget, that's an
especially dismal performance.
The production budget for Mortal Engines has
been reported as being over $100 million,
with the marketing budget reportedly being
$120 million, according to Deadline.
That means it may have cost in the realm of
$220 million to make and market Mortal Engines.
With such a lousy opening weekend, the movie
is pretty much doomed.
According to Deadline and other outlets, it
may well end up losing over $150 million by
the time its run is through.
Mortal Engines had the misfortune of debuting
during a crowded time of year.
On its debut weekend, it faced off against
Sony's Spider-Man: Into the Spider-Verse,
an animated superhero feature that topped
the domestic box office.
It also faced surprising competition from
Clint Eastwood's The Mule, which came out
to one of the best financial performances
of the director's career.
And those are just the brand-new movies.
Audiences also spent the weekend with family
films like The Grinch or the Wreck-It Ralph
sequel, still holding strong after several
weeks in theaters.
Other big movies audiences are still catching
up on include Creed II, Bohemian Rhapsody,
and the Fantastic Beasts sequel, with Once
Upon a Deadpool - the re-edited, PG-13 version
of Deadpool 2 - also peeling away a few million
dollars worth of viewers for itself.
"You dropped a super duber dumperuski in your
little diapey wipey, didn't you, buddy?"
"Yes I did."
Basically, there's no shortage of decent movies
to choose from in winter 2018.
While Mortal Engines may have distinguished
itself from the rest of the pack with its
weird premise, it totally failed to get people
interested in actually seeing it.
A movie doesn't need great reviews to be a
success at the box office.
But Mortal Engines proved a turn-off to audiences
and critics both.
"That must've been one lousy movie."
After its opening weekend, Mortal Engines
sat at a mere 28% on Rotten Tomatoes, with
129 reviews being counted toward the movie's
average score.
Writers referred to the movie as being wearying,
crummy, and a giant slog, with even the more
positive reviews typically finding something
to complain about.
While some gave credit to the movie's special
effects, it seemed the movie's story failed
to justify the spectacle.
Compare this reception to a movie like Spider-Verse,
which is a recognizable franchise movie getting
universal acclaim.
Next to offerings like that, Mortal Engines
just looks like too much of a risk.
Mortal Engines' biggest problem may be that
it's too difficult to advertise.
The cities-on-wheels idea is just too high-concept,
and wasn't explained in a compelling way by
the movie's marketing.
This is less of a problem for a book series,
which gets time to build a world over many
pages.
But movies have to sell themselves with intriguing
posters, killer trailers, and concepts that
could fit in a single sentence.
For a story that's this out there, that's
a pretty tricky proposition.
Complicating things is the fact that the book
series Mortal Engines is based on is relatively
unpopular in the United States, compared to
series like The Hunger Games or Harry Potter.
So Mortal Engines largely had to sell itself
on its merits as a movie.
It apparently made for a hard sell.
Imagining cities on wheels in a book is one
thing, but when you see them chasing each
other across the landscape in a movie trailer,
it's easy to just be confused.
Mortal Engines was produced in part by Peter
Jackson and Fran Walsh, with a screenplay
by Jackson, Walsh, and Philippa Boyens.
They're a creative team that rang in the new
millennium with their adaptations of The Lord
of the Rings, making a stone-cold classic
trilogy of movies that remain the gold standard
for epic book adaptations.
But whatever magic helped to elevate those
films to Oscar-sweeping greatness failed to
come into being with Mortal Engines, with
the property simply failing to generate enough
interest among audiences.
One reason why the movie failed is lousy timing
when it comes to cinematic trends.
Jackson originally purchased the rights to
the Mortal Engines story over a decade ago,
when adaptations of young adult novels were
more in fashion.
Now the landscape is much different, and audiences
apparently aren't as attracted to these stories
as they used to be.
The Darkest Minds, another YA adaptation released
in August 2018, also proved a flop on its
opening weekend.
But that movie had a much smaller budget,
so its failure caused less damage.
Mortal Engines was a big bet that didn't pay
off.
Whether the filmmakers thought people would
come out for the property, or for Peter Jackson,
they were wrong.
Nobody wanted to see it at all.
It was supposed to be a franchise-starter,
but instead it's ended up a fascinating failure.